hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm so they're gonna be
concluding our coverage of the 2015 as
Zurich chess challenge been a pretty
awesome tournament so far ten rounds of
awesome chess with the top players in
the world we have five rounds of
classical vision on actually won that
portion by a slim margin over Nakamura
by one point and then in the rapid
portion while neither player did a win
Nakamura did edged out fishing on by one
point so we actually have a tie and the
Zurich chess challenge has a pretty
interesting tiebreaker it's the
Armageddon format if you're not too
familiar with that it's a blitz style
format and there has to be a winner and
if black ties then black is actually
deemed the winner so because black has a
slight advantage there white actually
gets more time so Vichy and on is
actually gonna be playing the white
pieces he's gonna be given five minutes
on board which is still not a lot of
time and black played by nakamura is
gonna get four minutes so he has a
minute disadvantage but again if he
draws he's going to win so not still
sure how I feel about crowning the
champion based on the Armageddon format
but it is very very interesting to see
such a prestigious event being won on a
blitz style game at the very end on a
tiebreaker so hopefully you guys enjoy
definitely an exciting game vision on
starts out no surprise to anyone with
pawn here to d4 pawn d5 upon C for
Queens gambit Queens game decline line
opted for Nakamura and they actually
played this exact same format early in
the tournament in the classical series
where vision on actually won by a slight
margin Knight c3 a bishop ear to e7
Knight f3 Knight f6 Bishop here it's f4
fishing on lately has just really really
been a fan of getting the dark square
Bishop out before he plays the pawn here
to e3 Castle pawn here to e3 97 pawn up
here to c5 and then Knight to h5 kind of
going through these moves a little
quickly because again this is move for
move verbatim how they did earlier and
so you can kind of watch that we did
some coverage of that game earlier in
the week from here vision on opted for a
little bit more aggressive approach
before he played Bishop here to d3
instead in this particular game decided
to first play Bishop here to e5 and then
after a pawn here to c6 he's going for
broke here he's playing pawn here to g4
trying to push through on the kingside
nakamura has a little bit easier side on
the Queen side to break through so he's
going for broke on the King side
recognizing that hey I won the game
before where I played this setup where I
played bishop here to d3 but let's try
to complicate things because again he
only has five minutes and he has to win
or he is the loser so going for broke
here with pawn here to g4 Nakamura just
playing a little safe Knight back here
to f6 rook here to g1 getting ready to
just kind of support this pawn as it
pushes forward Knight taking here on e5
trying to relieve some of the pressure
in the center of the board after the
recapture met up here to d7 Nakamura
okay exchanging pieces off the board
again if he ties he wins so this is a
you know all good for not come more pawn
up here to f4 so Nakamura just letting
visi and on throw everything at him on
the Kings side and now deciding to
counter-attack on the Queen side
recognize it he doesn't want to try to
do anything crazy on the King side vichy
nods kind of owning this so he wants to
start chipping away in the fastest way
is starting with pawn here to be six now
pawn up here to b4 pawn down here to a5
it would have been interesting also if
you would have played let's say pawn
here to e5 completely breaking up the
center of the board
now that vision ons kind of played this
pawn here to f4 his king is gonna be
exposed the rest of the game so if we
had you know pawn to e5 let's say black
plays Bishop here to g5 threatening this
pawn it's gonna be very difficult for
fishing on to really play defense with
such limited time now if he had if we're
in a classical game he could definitely
find the right way to defend this but
this would be very very difficult for
him the other bishop could get involved
into the game this Queen could get
involved so that would be very very
difficult but typically what you see in
these blitz tile formats is one side
kind of has a plan and they kind of
stick with that plan right now
nakamura plan is attack the
inside and so that's what he continues
to do with pawn here to a5 vision plays
pawn to a3 supporting after the capture
here the Queen's gonna come up here to
be AIT's just getting a little bit more
involved into the action also attacking
the square here on f4 pawn up here to g5
so this she trying to extend a little
bit on the Kings side I'm not really
sure how he's gonna break through on
Nakamura's King side he's actually
pretty well defended here with all his
pawns in front his minor pieces adding a
little bit of protection so not really
sure kind of the plan that he has but
you know he can't really do too much on
the Queen side Nakamura kind of has that
on lockdown decides to kind of open it
up a little bit more and now he brings
his queen down here to b4 have you
thought a little bit longer which I
recognize he does not have a lot of time
here
Queen to b2 is just it's better it's
attacking kind of the same squares it's
you know for one attacking this rook
here on a1 kind of forcing the rook to
do something either the rook hangs this
knight hangs or this pawn here on h2
hangs now that may just be too much
complication that Nakamura doesn't want
to have to deal with so instead he just
decides you know the Queen here to be
for pinning down this Knight now that
rook comes over here to c1 a vichy and
on just forced to play defense right now
which is exactly what Nakamura wants
again all he has to do is get a draw
that's kind of what he's going for or
when would be great as well
rook down here to a3 Queen up here to d2
playing defense Bishop here to d8
Nakamura has the bishop here but he's
not doing too much so decides that he
wants to go ahead and get his Bishop
involved into the game after the knight
back here to d2 Nakamura is completely
okay exchanging Queens off the board now
the bishop can get involved into the
game this bishop here on f1 isn't doing
too much this rook here on G one's not
doing too much and this Knight it's
almost like it hasn't been developed at
all in the game so this chignon
definitely has some work to do king over
here to e2 rook over here to be AIT's
getting ready to get involved into the
action King up here to f3 not real clear
you know where vision on should really
go from here but pawn to e5 really just
breaks open
the game for Nakamura he can now get his
light-square bishop involved into the
action after the pawn takes we now see
the bishop here to f5 so you know
Nakamura is now controlling the center
of the board with both of his bishops he
has control with his d5 pawn of these
central squares here on c4 and he for he
can now easily get his other rook
involved into the game so it's gonna be
very difficult for vichy not to do too
much the next move from him I thought
was a little strained again there's not
tons of great moves but I think even at
a lower level chest he could see that
after his rook here to g2 the bishop
here to e4 on this nice little outpost
from the pawn is gonna force the King to
move and he's going to lose this rook
after the bishop recaptures rook down
here to a2 attacking the bishop after
the bishop moves bishop down here to d2
and this rook on c1 is lost there's no
way that he can move and not lose that
rook so vision on decides to go ahead
pack it in and shake the hand of
nakamura nakamura congratulations to him
he was kind of my my pick to win from
the beginning after he won round one he
just looked really good he actually
wanted the tournament he just played in
Gibraltar so he is playing phenomenal
chess winning back-to-back tournaments
it gets again some of the strongest
competition in the world so hopefully he
continues his run we've needed a chess
champion to just dominate tournaments
for a while and Americans to do that so
awesome to see that Congrats to all the
other competitors played some great
chess hopefully you guys enjoyed the
coverage try to be doing a lot more
coverage of tournaments throughout the
year but hopefully you guys learn
something and I'll see you guys the next
video thanks for watching